Canadians are being asked to roll up
their sleeves once more to get another
covid-19 booster shot the national
advisory committee on immunization or
Nasi said Tuesday vaccine makers are
developing a new formulation of the
vaccine to Target current variants and
they should be available in the coming
months if you plan to book your
appointment this fall you should still
wait at least six months since your
previous vaccine dose or known covet
infection before doing so Nasi says the
booster is especially important for
those over 65 years long-term care home
residents pregnant people and those at
high risk due to underlying medical
conditions those belonging to First
Nations metis and Inuit communities
should also receive a booster as well as
members of racialized communities and
essential workers
Dr Shelly deak says while the virus can
Peak at any time of the year the
recommendation for a fall dose is in
part due to the strain the Health Care
System sees during fall and winter
months
now covid-19 has seen a drop in cases
since the height of the pandemic with
new cases having decreased or plateaued
across Canada but so has vaccine uptake
while the World Health Organization
declared in May covid-19 was no longer a
global Health Emergency they still
cautioned the virus remained a threat it
also outlined priority use groups for
vaccines with high-risk people such as
health care workers and the
immunocompromise recommended to get
additional booster doses
people who have not yet been vaccinated
at all are also being encouraged to get
the current bivalent Omicron mRNA
vaccine which can be used for those
receiving their first two-do series it's
not yet known when the new doses will be
available as regulatory review has not
yet been completed but more information
is expected in the coming months Sean
preville Global News